but the formative activity has not only
this positive significance that in at
the pure being for self of the surveil
consciousness acquires an existence it
also has in contrast with its first
moment the negative significance of fear
for in fashioning the thing the
bondsman's own negativity his being for
self becomes an object for him only
through his setting at not the existing
shape confronting him but this objective
negative moment is none other than the
alien being before which it is troubled
now however he destroys this alien
negative moment posits himself as a
negative and the permanent order of
things and thereby becomes for himself
someone existing on his own account in
the war the being for self is an other
for the bondsman whereas only for him ie
is not his own in fear the beating for
self is present in the bondsman himself
in fashioning the thing he becomes aware
that being for self belongs to him
that he himself exists essentially and
actually in his own right the shape does
not become something other than himself
through being made external to him for
it is precisely the shape that is as
pure being herself which in this
externality is seen by him to be the
truth through this rediscovery of
himself by himself the bondsman realizes
that is precisely in his work where and
he seemed to have only an alienated
existence that he acquires a mind of his
own for this reflection the two moments
of fear and services such as also that a
formative activity are necessary both
being at the same time in a universal
mode without the discipline of service
and obedience fear remains at the formal
stage and does not extend to the known
real world of existence without the
formative activity
in Word and mute and consciousness does
not become explicitly for itself if
consciousness fashions the thing without
that initial absolute fear it is only an
empty self-centered attitude for its
former negativity is not negativity per
se and therefore its formative activity
cannot give it a consciousness of itself
as essential being if it has not
experienced absolute fear but only some
lesser dread the negative being has
remained for its something external its
substance has not been infected by it
through and through since the entire
contents of its natural consciousness
have not been jeopardized determinate
being still in principle attaches to it
having a mind of one's own is self-will
a freedom which is still a meshed and
servitude just as little as the pure
form can become essential being for it
just as little is that form regarded as
extended to the particular a universal
formative activity an absolute notion
rather it is a skill which is master
over some things but not over the
universal power and the whole of unit of
objective being
in this final paragraph 196 the last
paragraph of the master-slave dialectic
we have reached a very important turning
point we have developed the shape of
consciousness or actually two shapes of
consciousness the master and the slave
and as we've seen it's the slave on
whose side the initiative now lies the
slave is going to continue to develop
and this isn't the end of the story or
else we wouldn't have stoicism
scepticism and the unhappy consciousness
immediately following this so what is
Hegel going to do to bring all of this
together there's really two main things
happening in this this paragraph that I
want to call your attention to one is
we're going to look at this whole
diagram here and what's going on with
that it looks rather complicated it is
rather complicated but it could be
summarized in saying that the slave
becomes aware of his or her
self-identity through their
externalization of themselves into the
world of products into the world of
artifacts into the world of things which
they formed you notice that I've also
got these three things up here at the
top fear service and formation or
formative activity first deena and
building this is the second thing that's
going on in this pyramid Hegel is going
to insist that if this development is
going to occur so you realize that this
is an if not a automatic sort of thing
these three conditions have to be met
and they have to be met fully or
adequately they can't just be partially
fulfilled so what this means is that not
every human being who is thrown into the
position of servitude is automatically
going to develop in this way this is
something that requires certain
circumstances to to come together all
right so that's that what's going on
with all this stuff
Hegel starts out this this paragraph by
saying that there is a positive and a
negative significance to what's occurred
right the positive significance lies in
the formative activity the building and
when we see this word building we ought
to think build dawn as well the the more
substantive firm form of it firm of it
form because the slave is not merely
imparting form or shape or structure or
utility to objects the slave is also
doing so to him or herself in the
process and Bill doing is culturation it
is formation of the person it's part of
what we do in in real education not you
know just throw a whole bunch of things
that here and give you a multiple choice
test kind of Education the negative
aspect the negative dimension is fear
and Hegel is being stressed to us that
both these sides are operative at the
same time in what is going on the
formative activity is positive
significance it also has the negative
significance of fear what here's where
we get to the the charm right in
fashioning the thing the bondsman's own
negativity is being for self becomes an
object for him that means that the slave
now we saw that the slave is able to
grasp their own being for self the
master has being for self with the slave
also has being for self but they grasp
it by negating it as an object they how
do they negate it as an object partly by
what they subject themselves to it's not
just a master who subjects the slave the
slave can only really be a slave when he
or she also subjects him or herself and
in doing so it seems like the master
totally wins right but in reality what
Hegel is saying is if this occurs in the
right circumstances it's the slave who
something the slave wins a kind of
independence in this process so he says
in fashioning the thing right in
informing in working upon the thing
that's that's what's going on over here
the by the the bondsman all negativity
becomes an object for him through his
setting yet not the existing shape
confronting him and that setting yet not
is an outcome is a sublation so the the
fact that a human being works upon
things and transforms them from being
you know things in their raw on the
finished state to formed products form
structures things that are accessible to
human desires human needs subject to be
used in trade can be stored can be
transformed further into other things
generating an entire world culture a
world of artifacts a world of meanings
even so far as is the human activity of
the slave that is doing so and and in
this respect you know
slaves are you know replaceable slaves
are substitutable we don't mean
necessarily this guy to be the farmer
you can put another farmer in his place
that's part of what's going on here
there is a sublation a negation and
overcoming the resistance of the thing
this is a massive human achievement
that's taking place here one that we
take for granted because we are just
used to it happening all the time where
were the heirs of this long historical
process of hard-won culture right so he
says it becomes about going through
through descending it not the existing
shape confronting them but the
subjective negative moments this
negating moment this being herself is
none other than the alien being before
which yes the slave has trembled this is
working in two different ways
the being for self of the slave is in
fact the being of the master the master
also has being for self insult
consciousness the master is the source
of the fear of the slave right because
the master can kill the slave without
behind there's of course death the
absolute master sure but the Masters
long we can actually take the sword and
run you through or work you to death or
put you know tie you up and throw you
into a ditch until you die of exposure
like that happened in Plato's Euthyphro
and what happens here though this is
where it gets really interesting the
slave internalizes their fear the slave
analyzes the source of the fear the
master that becomes part of the
consciousness on the slave let me say
this again the slave is not merely
conscious of the master as something
totally external extrinsic imposing
force demanding labor you know imposing
some sort of unfortunate and unwanted
power structure upon them the slave
internalizes the master and makes the
master part of the slaves own
consciousness and that is what allows
the slave to negate this that was what I
was the slave to in a real way say no so
he says he destroys this alien negative
moment and he posits himself as a
negative in the permanent order of
things one of the permanent orders this
is the order of things the order of the
world that has been generated and the
order of those who take part in creating
in forming and shaping and renewing
and continually recirculating that world
in making that world continue on so he
says he posits himself as a negative in
the permanent order of things and
becomes therefore thereby becomes for
himself
somebody existing on his own account not
no longer is the slave only the slave of
the master only having his or her
significance in what they can do what
they can provide what could be done to
them by the master or for the master the
slave now has independence of some sort
it's not a complete independence of
course if the slave shows up to work and
says look I discovered by working on
objects that I am also self
consciousness just as much as you are
and I have rejected the you know the
negation all aspect that's been you know
keeping me in check here and a little
bit unhappy with the way that you talk
to me and the work that you get me if
this lady does that important thing the
master is going to fire them or kill
them or do something else and then the
slave very quickly will realize you know
that I deal that I do that the ideal is
not the same thing as the actual that
the rational is not yet the real and
that a lot more development needs to
take place but within the consciousness
of the slave there is this independence
the slave has become aware of themselves
as an independent being so it says in
the Lord the being for self is an other
for the bondsman or is only for him in
fear the being for self is present in
the bondsman himself let me say that
again so in the Lord the object of fear
being for self is an other in the pin in
the bondsman right or is only for him
but in fear in what the bondsman the
slave the servant feels we
different deeper meaning going on here
like he says in fashioning the thing he
becomes aware that being for self
belongs to him
why because by fashioning the thing he
has to pay attention not only to the
thing and what he's transforming it into
he has to pay attention to the fact that
he is the one who's doing this she
becomes somebody responsible somebody
who is not just a mediator between the
master and the thing by you know
providing him the the best parts of it
but by being a person who actually
understands the thing and understands
and can make his way around the world of
things this realm of independence that
in relation to the master is now
starting to look pretty pale pretty uh
you know weak in many respects pretty
ghostly so the slave is becoming aware
of who he is through his work through
the service that he owes to the master
through the forming activity upon the
thing he says he becomes aware that
being for self belongs to him that he
himself exists essentially and actually
in his own right if the slave decides
that he's not going to do the work that
day the work won't get done now of
course you can find another slave to do
the work but it'll still require doing
that and in many cases if the slave
doesn't do the work the work won't
happen and the master is going to be in
many respects screwed in a position
where they can't get what they need
the master will then probably have to
resort to doing some of the work him or
herself so we go on you see he says the
shape does not become something other
than himself through being made external
to him for it is precisely this shape
that is his pure being force up we come
again to the formative activity
what happens when a person is working
upon things and and transforming them
into something else that can satisfy
desires that can meet human needs is it
just a activity where I'm not putting
anything of myself into that thing or
when I'm really working am i indeed
externalizing myself into the world so I
can say I did that
that is my product that is something
that is from me there's a little bit of
me in it so he says through this
rediscovery of himself buying himself
the bondsman realizes it is precisely in
his work in his work this whole complex
here four main service he felt that he
was alienated he felt that in this he
was just being treated as less than
human he was not able to make sense of
what he was who he was what little sense
he could make of it he wasn't happy with
that it seemed as if the the master is
getting everything that's great over
here wouldn't it be wonderful to be a
master but it turns out that the slave
by engaging in this very process has
discovered who he or she really is what
he or she really is what it is to be a
human being because they are a human
being they are human being in its
existence which is the only way that
human being has any real presence so he
says for this reflection here's where we
get to this other part here for this
reflection the two moments of fear and
services such as also that a formative
activity are necessary
these beating at the same time in a
universal mode right so if we don't have
fear this process doesn't happen if we
don't have service this process doesn't
happen if we don't have a formative
active
this process doesn't happen notice what
we need to have for this for fear and
for service we need another in the
position of the master so we can't do
this all by ourselves Hegel is here
rejecting any sort of theory of human
origins that would say that in our
original state you know we're just
completely free and we work on things
and then we started you know dealing
with each other and only after they have
to we have power relations Hegel is
saying no power relations are there if
we're going to have human development
from the very beginning their inherent
in the nature of self-consciousness not
necessarily in the sense that we're
doomed
to power failures it is something that
we want to eventually surpass and we
will in fact see many better shapes of
this but it is something that is
inherent in the human condition this
other and this other that we're serving
could be in fact a human master it could
be the gods thinking again about the
Babylonian animal ish that I've brought
up before at the end of the numeral ish
which is an origin story there's a quite
cool or lots of fighting going on there
betrayals anger lots of a really great
stuff the gods are unwilling to serve
each other
so they create human beings why so the
gods won't have to get into conflict
with each other because they have a
servant class of beings human beings
that they make and they make him out of
the blood of a defeat of God it could be
any sort of thing that's occupying a
position of the master but there has to
be something occupying that position or
you're not going to have the service
that takes place and you're not going to
have the fear that's required that's not
enough though you also need the
formative activity the engagement with
Thanks so let's see how Hegel parses
this out he says without the discipline
of service and obedience fear remains
and what he calls the formal stage fear
is just something we feel but it doesn't
go anywhere it doesn't mean anything we
just feel afraid right without the
discipline of service and obedience what
are the discipline of service and
obedience introducing this is not
something that he talks about here but
it is something very important dimension
of temporality fear is something that we
feel and feelings can go on for time
right but feelings can also disappear
very quickly they can add and flow what
gives the the fear of some sort of
constancy that allows the fear to be
able to mean something for the human
being is the fact that they are within a
temporal matrix not just a you know
succession of moments but rather a
succession of activities a succession of
relations that are going on and on and
on there's a repetition involved in the
service that's taking place here so he
says it doesn't extend to the known real
world of existence if it remains just at
that formal stage without the formative
activity on the other hand without
turning to the thing fear remains inward
and mute so you can put somebody in a
position where they're afraid of you and
they have to do things for you but
unless they're actually having to engage
with other things perhaps other persons
or other things that's not going to
cause any sort of development the fear
remains in wordid mute and consciousness
does not become explicitly for itself
why because it only becomes for itself
as it externalizes itself into its
products now he goes on he says if
consciousness fashion is the thing with
our to that initial absolute fear which
is coming
master but then has to be internalized
felt as something that turns one's
entire perspective and existence upside
down calls everything into question
shapes things to their foundations if
you don't have that he says it's only an
empty self-centered attitude its form of
or negativity is not negativity
perceived it lacks a universal human
dimension to it
it's only about me it's my fear and not
fear felt or understood as fear for
human reality in general so he says then
then if that happens here we go
it's former negativity is not negativity
per se its formative activity cannot
give it give it a consciousness of
itself it has a central being I can't
see myself as no longer just Greg Sadler
but humanity yeah that's very important
for Hegel says if it's not experienced
absolute fear but only some lesser dread
the negative being has remained for it
something external the negative being is
the master and the negative being is the
world of products if it hasn't
experienced absolute fear then it is he
says that substance has not been
infected by it through and through and
so since the entire contents of its
natural consciousness what does he mean
by its natural consciousness its
attachment to where it is who it is what
it thinks itself to be the life that it
was unwilling to abandon if it hasn't
abandoned that if the contents of its
natural consciousness have not been
jeopardized says determinate being still
in principle attaches to it and here he
says having a minds of what having a
mind of one's own onions in stubbornness
as we translate that a sort of you know
being stuck in one's own attitude and
not being able to be receptive to what
else is going on
I in Zhen is remaining trapped in a self
perspective and not grasping oneself as
being related to others and being part
of a general universal humanity so all
of these are required for that to
develop this is in certain respects a
kind of tragic view on human beginnings
it's not a tragic view about where we're
going but it does say that you can't
have any real development without you
know somebody working for somebody else
without you know engaging in objects but
also without somebody scaring the hell
out of somebody else and making them so
scared that they literally turn inside
out that they they become a whole
different person because of it so this
is a very important development he goes
on he says in this case just as little
of the pure form can become essential
being for it just as little is that form
as regarded extended to the particular a
universal formative activity and
absolute notion so when this does occur
what that means is the slave through his
or her activity through internalizing
the fear through serving becomes
universal the masters no longer the
universal side the slave is the
universal side they engage with the
absolute notion the concept they are
aware dialectical development can now
occur so he says instead you get a skill
which is master over some things but not
over the universal power and the whole
of objective being so what does Hegel
saying here to us slavery in certain
circumstances servitude when it's
combined with these things opens up the
possibility for the development of a new
shape of human consciousness which did
occur in history now that brings us to a
good stopping point here but also some
further reflections that we want to
think of is Hegel saying that this
provides us this whole section with a
map of exactly what took place is this
sort of his his replacement of you know
Hobbes's Leviathan you know the origin
of human beings or jean-jacques
Rousseau's you know discussion of the
origin of human beings and the discourse
on inequality or pick whatever other you
know account of human origins you like
no he's not saying that this is a map
for history itself things are of course
much more complicated when we get to
determinate cultures and how people
related to each other but it is saying
this provides us with an outline for
understanding how human culture is
developing in terms of
self-consciousness and in terms that are
going to lead us to this next section
which begins with stoicism and it's good
to keep in mind that you know stoicism
is not something that comes on the scene
immediately in the beginning of
primitive societies it actually comes
about in Hellenistic society after quite
a you know quite a lot of development
has occurred
same thing with skepticism same thing
with what he's calling the unhappy
consciousness that particular shapes of
religion that we're going to be looking
at but slavery and the master-slave
dialectic the way that Hegel is
articulated where the key thing is that
the slave actually becomes independent
and realizes that through their their
work and through dealing with their fear
is a necessary precursor for that in
Hegel's view of human developments in
history in consciousness so we come now
to the end of the master-slave dialectic
one
the most famous portions of Hegel's text
I hope that this has been particularly
illuminating for you it's been very
enjoyable for me myself to get up here
in front of the board and scribble away
and and try to leave you through all of
this and I think that's pretty much all
that we have to say
now on to stoicism skepticism and the
unhappy consciousness
you